Dancing with the Stars returns on Monday
I'm Nancy O'Dell with eg now and prices
right host Drew Carey as one of the
season 18 cast members and we found out
that his partner Cheryl Burke is
actually more worried about his weight
loss than his dance moves
you're saying that you're scary thin I
need to lose about I need to lose about
ten pounds yeah he's down 80 pounds but
his drew too skinny we all remember when
there was more of him to love but the 55
year old is on a mission to shrink even
more I thought oh this would be a great
way to lose the 10 pounds is it be on
Dancing with the Stars wait till we do
the other dances so far Scrooge
you might seem like a dancing new beat
but we did some digging in our ET vaults
and look at what we found
dreams dancing flashback et was there
back in 1996 when he shot a big
production number for The Drew Carey
Show and we just had to show him it's a
tough job doing two Network shows Andrew
does have that other gig on CBS all you
do is just give away cars how hard can
that be
gonna pay title so she rolls past
partners include hotties like a Joe
Marini William Levy and Chad Ochocinco
and the chemistry she creates makes it
seem as if there's something going on so
are there sparks between Cheryl and Drew
we're keeping it PG here yeah this is a
professional thing here oh man not even
hugged well we can't wait to see them
but to move up dance floor March the
17th and you could tune in to et on TV
tonight see more of the best
entertainment news coverage I'm Nancy
O'Dell with ET now